all right one of y'all Welcome To The
Dress pearly things YouTube channel
today I am going to be talking about how
I triggered Twitter yesterday I just got
out of the gym
you know I got some rude comments saying
that I was a bit chunky which anyone
that's followed the channel knows
I'm down like 20 pounds this year but
you know and I was like you know what
thank you for the extra motivation so
yesterday I triggered Twitter
I triggered Twitter and I have this
problem where what I'll do is I'll just
like tweet random thoughts and I'll
tweet tweet tweet tweet tweet right and
me I don't really like how I put it I'm
pretty open-minded so I I'm not like
trying to die on any of these Hills I'm
just like out here like thinking and so
I tweet thoughts and what I don't
realize is that a lot of these people
take Twitter very seriously they're very
serious tweeters
um
we're me I'm just like throwing around
ideas
so and sometimes I get into these
Twitter like to me I don't see it as an
argument I see this like a discussion
but then I get started called being
called a and I'm like a I
thought we were just throwing around
ideas so and what I realized last time
is it this was with a pretty big
YouTuber I've never heard of her you
know I'm not really on
the I think she's like uh there's like
these conservative
feminist like women that they're
basically feminists but they're
conservatives uh you have to
once you see it you can't I think that's
who it is but yesterday I tweeted and
there is one tweet
that really made the internet mad
because I've been recently deciding to
go on on the Sims and a lot of these
reaction channels they're really just
simps that tell women what they want to
hear
not just reaction channels but these
guys on TV and it pisses me off because
they're lying to us they're lying to us
and selling us this dream that isn't
real all right so and it pisses me off
because men know the truth they know
what's true and what's not and they
continue to push
things that are liars like that that are
lies
hold on I have to I tweet it gosh I
tweeted a lot last night
um
so
what sparked this thought
is
I thought of a friend okay here I found
the tweet this got 1.1 million views
wow
people were not feeling this they were
not okay I said simps will tell women
it's perfectly acceptable to get
divorced over small things like finances
chores cheating or not being happy simps
will tell women to put their kid at
every statistical disadvantage for their
own feelings
now what do you think triggered the
internet the cheating all right now why
did I say this even now all that we got
the Christians mad too the Christians
come and say hey hey they're knocking on
my door they're saying hey God says we
can get divorced over cheating now
there's some
Christians that say God does not say
that there's some Christians that say
God does say that no I'm not a die-hard
religious person okay
I do believe in God I do pray but I
wouldn't say I'm like the most I went to
Catholic school I got a Bible you know
but I I wouldn't say I'm the most
educate like there's just people that
know more than me okay
why did I say this so I have a friend
right
and her I have two friends actually too
that I'm thinking of both were involved
in cheating
so both were in marriages where their
husbands were Unfaithful okay and one
friend's mom worked it out and she
actually passed away recently she lived
to be about like 60 65
um and she um Jose
her husband was always stepping out he
was cheating left and right walled when
he was a bit younger like in his I think
30s or 40s and this woman stuck by him
worked it out and when she passed away
she was still married and she died in
his arms with her two kids
and my friend always said she was really
thankful that her mother worked it out
um because they could oh my gosh I
thought of another friend because they
could have gotten divorced
and would the outcome have been better
for her as a single woman with two
children
in her I don't know 30s and 40s that I
don't actually know what age it was
because she's older my friend
um on The Dating Market
now I have another friend who's who's
dad did the exact same thing exact same
thing but they're still together and her
dad
um
also cheated she came to found out when
she was a little older that her mother
wasn't sleeping with her father
so you know while we could demonize the
dad for stepping out we didn't really
talk about the mother's part to play in
this okay
um and my point is this that both of
those things seemed like really big
things at the time they seemed huge but
in the grand scheme of things in their
marriage it became a small thing
and
and okay so let me let me just put some
oh and then some guy replied to this and
said I've been a side dude to this
married woman for five years and she
thinks about divorcing her husband I
legit encourage her to stay and think
about what's best for the kids I'm like
Ross
that is not what I meant
that's not what I meant what are you
talking about Okay so
then I go up all right they say small
so the then all the church people
will come in and say well like God says
we can get divorced and the question I
have
is should we
should we get divorced
over cheating is that is that a better
outcome for women I'm thinking about the
women okay the simps are thinking about
what sounds good to women I'm thinking
about the actual women
now I want to read you guys some stats
okay wait let me find this this all
right
single mother homes account for 63
percent of all youth suicides seventy
percent of all teen pregnancies 71
percent of all adolescent chemical
substance abusers eighty percent of all
prison inmates ninety percent of all
runaway children come from single mother
homes
so
we don't think
that may be the first response I am not
saying that there are never instances
that cheating we need to get divorced
over but considering
that they're saying 20 to 40 percent of
marriages
and because of infidelity
you don't think that they're set I mean
I don't there's so many stats for the
reasons that marriage is in like God
only knows but I'm I'm hearing this is
one of the number one reasons that we
get divorced so we shouldn't have a
conversation as women saying you know
what this might happen in our marriage
this might and what are we gonna do if
it does
so then you know you start talking to
the men that had these Unfaithful things
right
and you start to hear from them and
they're saying well my wife hadn't slept
with me in two years
and it's funny because what the
Christians will say
is they'll say well he should have left
well
most men don't want to lose half their
stuff and only see their kids six days a
month
most men will literally stick out a
sexless marriage for children but women
cannot stick out a cheating marriage for
children that's the crazy part
um
I think we should be equally
as judgmental of the woman that does not
sleep with her husband and puts him in
that position as the man that steps out
because that really isn't fair
and I think that's a conversation as
women we really need to have like okay
this might happen and if it does happen
are we gonna stay or are we gonna go
and I think that the default should
always be stay
yes I know maybe this is crazy
so I said are Christians really arguing
with me that working out cheating should
not be the first response for women in a
marriage
saying that women should work out
cheating is very different than excusing
the behavior and this is where the the
reaction channels TMZ fake news simps
will will misquote me
is the outcome now let's look at the
outcome for the women let's just say we
want the best outcome for women okay is
the outcome really going to be better
for a woman with children back on The
Dating Market Simpsons advise women to
leave at the cost of the children and
even their own best interest
and yes because then then the simps will
come in and say well well if the women
are you guys say women are better off
after divorce
yes there is a financial advantage to
incentive to leave for women to leave
marriage but
that does not mean that women are better
off in the long run they'll likely be
with a man that is less desirable or
single like come on let's just call
space debate are you gonna get a better
guy 25 in the dating Market even 30 in
childless in the dating Market or 42
with two kids what do you think is out
there
um they'll likely okay and what's sadder
than being alone for women in their
older years like do you really think
women are meant to be alone in our older
years now the simps will come in and say
well your husband might die he's
probably gonna die before you
fine fine is that the type of Legacy as
women we want to leave is it and this is
a genuine conversation for the women
symphs lie to women and tell us we can
expect it all life is about choices and
trade-offs and people aren't perfect and
now this is where I now
this is where I have the hardest time
with the women it is like if a man you
can't have this conversation with the
Christians I don't know why because we
should be on the same side it's like
okay if a guy cheats we can never talk
about did the woman contribute to that
cheating and is the woman innocent in
this if attention is to women as sexist
to men which I think it is then do you
think a man if a woman posts a
provocative picture on social media
should a man try to work that out
because they they should be the same and
we see men put up with that all of the
time we see women with open Instagram
accounts all of the time and yet if a
man cheats he's the devil but a woman
has an open Instagram account and a
marriage
um
and the simps will say leave him you
can't ever rebuild trust leave him but
the truth is that the grass isn't
greener on the other side and they're
lying to us they're lying
and so then I'm arguing with this
YouTuber and I don't actually know who
she is some girl named shu
now apparently I know it's funny because
again sometimes I go back and forth with
people and I don't realize that they
have
follow it like I don't know who they are
um and she said one of these small
things is not like the other and I said
is it impossible for cheating to be a
small thing in the grand scheme of
things and then they always the girls
always respond well my trust is broken
okay let's let's call a spade a spade
ladies have we never have you never in a
relationship or a marriage broke in a
guy's trust so you were perfect holier
than now you never flirted with another
guy in a marriage you never answered a
DM in a marriage you never did anything
anything you never wore something a bit
revealing to the gym you like and it's
just like insane to me that we are so
quick to say leave him when the outcomes
are not better for women so I started
looking up
the remarriage rate so if you leave your
husband there's only a 50 50 shot which
maybe you say that's high maybe that's
good there's a 50 50 shot you get
remarried and even if you get remarried
you're more likely to get divorced from
the second guy then stay so like let's
look at some examples is Jeff bezos's
wife in a better place now
everyone cheered her on oh he was a dog
he was a cheater and then so she leaves
marries the teacher everyone cheers her
on and now she's divorced single and old
is she in a better place and this is the
worst part I care about the results for
women the simps don't they want to sound
good in virtue signal and half of these
simps Have Cheated at some point
probably would cheat in the right
situations and they don't care they
don't care and that's my issue is that
we tell women that we can expect it all
we tell women yes you can have a tall
handsome successful man that's also
faithful to you and it's likely going to
happen it's not it's not and we can say
oh this is what it should be right
that's what we can say we could say this
is what life should be or we could talk
about what it is and if this is one of
the number one reasons for divorce Earth
maybe as women we should talk about if
we get married what are we going to do
and the real question is this comes down
to do you care about yourself or do you
care about the kids because
the kids are more important than you and
you're putting your kid at the
you're putting your kid at every
statistical disadvantage they're more
likely to be abused they're more likely
to run away from home they're more
likely to go to prison they're more
likely to be sexually abused by the step
dad
that's true is this going is this a
better outcome for the kids to have
random men in and out of the house
influencing your child is that better
for the children yet the Christians do
not want to have this conversation yet
they always want to say oh well he
shouldn't cheat in the first place we
agree but I live in the real world where
this is one of the number one reasons
for divorce
now let's talk about the exchange that
men and women give in relationships okay
what do the men get out of marriage they
get sex for life right that's what they
get they get loyalty typically
they don't sleep with other they give
don't sleep with other women
and by the way this is not me advocating
for cheating so stop putting that in
your goddamn reactions stop it but as
women let's have a conversation about
what are we going to do if it happens
all right don't so the men they get sex
for Life loyalty don't sleep with other
women historically we're going to talk
about a traditional if we go back to
what the Trad cons dream is
um they are a provider
slash protector
okay now the women would usually give
purity
youth
um
also loyalty
all right now let's talk about it the
average man makes more than the average
woman
so the average man is more of a provider
than the average woman
okay
oh
Beauty women give to
the average man is stronger than the
average woman so we can say okay maybe
men aren't as masculine as they used to
be there's still more of a protector and
more of a provider than women
now
is the average woman
more pure than the average man now if
you look at averages
sure
they the the average man has a higher
body count than the average woman but
when you take into account
the younger generation where one in
three men are sexless
and the younger generation where you see
that it's a small percentage of men
screwing all the girls
the average man is not
more sexually experienced than the
average woman therefore we do not give
Purity anymore that is gone that is gone
okay net and I'm gonna read some steps
youth average age of first marriage I'm
in the UK 31.
okay we don't give youth anymore
loyalty women initiate most of divorces
okay we're not loyal anymore a half of
marriage is end in divorce women always
initiate divorce most of the time
Beauty
sixty percent of us are overweight and
if you take into account extreme obesity
women are still fatter than men unlike
these fake ass simp ass reaction
channels that will mislead you and try
to paint it like men are fatter than
women but if you really look at the
stats and you take into account muscle
mass bone density and obesity women are
more obese than men therefore we do not
bring Beauty anymore not not what we
would do traditionally so the men are
more of protectors and providers they
still typically pay on dates women none
of us are virgins so we come in to be
honest subpar as a group I'm not trying
to say oh I'm so much better than
everybody blah blah blah but we come in
subpar and if the men
don't get live up to their end of the
bargain which they're supposed to be
loyal for a lifetime okay I'm gonna give
you guys that they're a hundred percent
supposed to cheating wrong oh and and
one in four marriages is sexless
one and four
so they don't even get the sex for life
anymore women get the two kids and I
hear this from divorce attorneys when we
get the two kids stop sleeping with
their husband so now now
there's they don't even get the sex for
life
so
it's like when women so women don't hold
the far end of the bargain
men don't hold up their end of the
bargain and they're demonized and I get
1.1 million views on a tweet saying we
should work out cheating now I'm going
to read you some stats okay and people
want to say I'm harping on women
and but I'm saying Ladies as a group how
can we say we're doing good okay as a
group when one in four women have an STD
one in three women have had an abortion
38 percent of kids are born into single
parent homes the average age of first
child is 26. average age of first
marriage is 30. they're predicting that
50 percent of us are going to be single
childless 45 of marriages end in divorce
women initiate 70 of the time the
average number of sexual partners is
between four and eight seventy percent
of oh it's actually 60. I got this wrong
60 of women are overweight ninety
percent of use contraceptives at some
point in their reproductive years and
most have used more than one
contraceptive method throughout their
lifetimes
foreign
not holding up our end of the bargain
okay clearly
but if the men don't hold up theirs then
they're the bad guy and we can never
talk about how the woman contributed to
that situation because you know I think
of all three women that got cheated on
that I know my three friends right oh
and I forgot to say
so the third friend's mother
ended up bitter alone and single
who got divorced over it so and I think
of the outcomes who was happier the
woman that stuck it out or the woman
that died alone
and that's the thing simps will tell us
to leave and that it's perfectly
reasonable you shouldn't work it out
but reasonable people will first ask how
did the women contribute to it we will
first ask was the woman's is her record
clean was she really doing nothing and a
lot of the time we're gonna find out
that the women had a part to play and
that's all I'm saying is that the
defaults if again if 20 percent
uh 20 to 40 percent of divorces is
because of infidelity that means it's
common
and that means that
we should have a conversation about what
will happen if it happens so I know my
audience hates me talking about cheating
and I don't even want to die on this
hill but what I can't stand is hypocrisy
the double standards and quite honestly
the simping I just can't stand it all
these Sims will tell us what we want to
hear but I look at what outcomes have
better results
there I said my piece on it
um I'm sorry for getting into a Twitter
war
I didn't mean it to be a war
also can we stop acting like women are
these big providers the average chick
makes 35k a year 35k
we are not
anyways like the video on your way out
guys subscribe to the channel
um I'm tired of these Sims goodbye